[Music]
wade miley he misses a lot of bats
particularly the sweet spot he's not a
strikeout man but
he avoids hard contact he was on the
injured list today his return
his first outing in a couple of weeks
and it's floated out toward left field a
base hit for oduba herrera
that's a good way to start the afternoon
a lead-off single here in the first
bounce back to miley he makes the glove
snaps it off to second
on the first double play max schrock the
pivot
as he filled in from second base at a
1-4-3
gideon should be mandatory
ground ball right side and that's a base
hit for reece he's had so many of those
during this stretch in the month of may
and low ball four now two odd
with two outs and it brings brad miller
up
pops that one up shallow left farmer
looping out
makes the call and catch on this
sunshiny day a scoreless first for wade
miley as the reds grab their bats
since velasquez making his seventh start
velasquez 2-0 on the year
2.95 era 1-2 pitch to suarez
swing it abyss got him with a breaking
ball and he's down on strikes one out
here in the bottom of the first
and a swing and a bouncer towards the
right side sugar has got it on two hops
quick flip to first
out to center field that sounded like it
was hit pretty good but oduba was there
so is miller i know double makes the
call in the catch
the side is retired one two three bottom
of the first for velasquez
we go to the second
and a lighter out toward right field
going back out at his castillanos it's
over his head he reaches up and makes
the leaping grab
one out here in the second yeah for a
guy that came up as a third baseman he
turned into a
you know pretty good right fielder
bouncer over to the left side and past
farmer head into left field
that'll be the third hit for the
phillies they have runners on first and
second
with one out
swing at a miss strike three first k for
miley
[Applause]
chop to second schrock swoops in makes
the glove clean exchange
that's the inning
and he calmly takes a four-pitch walk
first red to reach there's max schrock
with the runner at first nobody out
runner goes payoff is clubbed in the air
to right miller it started in he
retreats
and it's gone max schrock
elevated to the fifth spot in the lineup
david bell liked his swing the whole
stadium
loves that stroke a two-run homer
and it's nothing reds
that is hammered into right field it is
bp for the reds
barnhart speeds in the second standing
as he
wallops a pull double
to the plate payoff pitch up and in ball
four
togo akiyama draws a one-hour walk
checked his swing appeal he did not go
and there's another walk
the bases are loaded three walks on the
inning
base is full two outs here's tyler
naquin
and he ropes that one through the whole
right side base hit barnhart scores
akiyama given the green light miller
from right throws in
it's cut off infield grass suarez first
to third
a two-run single for tyler naquin and a
four-run
second inning the reds smothering the
phillies
i don't know how you can tell line drive
and that's a
fair ball down the left field line
kicking around the corner
that segura is on his way to second he
is there standing his ninth double of
the year
second double that he's had against
miley and now jt romuto is the hitter
sharply back to shortstop farmer throws
out real muto
segura scores it's an rbi for jt
and it's now a 4-1 ball game
swing into this second k for miley
phillies get their first run
the reds lead down to three mid-three
the pitchers i know would call that
pitch
swinging a miss threw him a change up
and he picked up his second strikeout
and there are two outs here in the third
two two opposite way into left base here
tucker barnhart a two for two start
kyle farmer who has seen his contact
rate dip
doesn't have a hit since the 26th and
that one well hit
in the air down the left field line fair
foul that is a fair ball
home run kyle farber
two out two run thunder and the reds
expand the lead at six to one
2-2 pitch on the way akiyama takes a
called third strike
fastball over the outer corner and
there's the third strikeout for vince
velasquez
my goodness amen to that john mccutchen
grounds one right up the middle a base
hit
no the board
down to a knee takes a tumble
big strikeout for wade miley his third
of the day
went away it takes strike three
another k for miley back to back
strikeouts
two down
swing and a miss went to the curve bowl
again lost briefly by barnhart
completing the put out
that's five k's wayne miley's getting a
lot of swings and misses here today
well he has found something
another way and that'll drop for a base
hit castellanos will
cut it off before it gets to the corner
and jt will pull into second base
and he's there standing with his eighth
double of the year
one two popped high in the air right
side of the infield
weaving makes the grab and that's the
inning
and he swings and grounds it through the
left side base hit and a 17-game hit
streak
alive and well for nick castellanos
[Music]
max schrock first pitch swinging deep
right center
over the leap of miller all the way to
the fence
castellanos given the windmill in third
by j.r house
throw in as no shot castellanos crosses
and max rock connects on the day of his
first reds home run
he drills a triple kyle farmer
two-run homer last time up
so there's a blooper to shallow center
farmer connects again schrock scores
two out rvi hit a three ribby day
for kyle farmer and the reds pouring it
on it's eight to one
you try to get pitchers early because if
you let them stay out there for long
they find a rhythm and that's what wade
miley has done
and there is strike three mccutcheon
goes down looking
that is six strikeouts for miley
well the phillies have david hale up
again as boehm
slaps that one to right castiano's well
read long strides
two down right back to miley
one two three enemy the game
gets later miley gets better
to left center chasing back herrera that
one bent by the wind as it skips to the
fence
house reads the outfielders late stop
sign for stevenson who stumbles
and head first plunges back into the bag
max schrock
is a single shy of the cycle and there's
an athletic training visit coming here i
think for schrock
schrock had a a calf strain that cost
him time earlier in the year
it looks like he's coming out and he's
very ginger with his stride as he comes
off the field
opposite away down base hits
a career day for kyle farmer
stevenson scores blandino scores
barnhart over to third five
ribbies for kyle farmer and a
10-1 red drop
hales pitch bounced right side runners
advance
they can see the run and miller makes
the throw barnhart scores farmer takes
third
11 to one rings
jonathan india lays out and makes the
catch
game over ball game reds
the middle infield clobbers the baseball
wade miley
and the bullpen hold the phillies to a
run
and the reds drop in their home stand
opener